allora quindi questa quella mappa
veramente più difficile di forza non più
difficile ma comunque tra le più
difficili ma è la chiesa che divisi ma
grazie ragazza bene potere ai piccoli
voglio uscire con rischi la cosa non è
quella di meno è quello di lavoro agli
vedono e questa trappola ma non è questo
male ma come è possibile
ma chi neanche troll si no da questo
livello adesso poi ok va bene allora
andiamo io mio rispetto ha fatto cose ma
veloce l'ho fatto un pezzettino tech è
troppo lento e rendere trappole
ritrovava e ancora di trappole coli
trappole però dai non era male ma
partenza ogni volta che vuoi il bonus
mia visi e di dalla spiegazione di come
si fanno a ok perché c'è una spiegazione
grazie sentito come ci si possa dare una
mano ai primi livelli penso al suo corto
che ha mollato anche nella vita se c'è
un limite per tutto ma bellissimo che
non sapevo
vabbè ci proviamo bello vero mi piace
allora perché tu ci hai provato già
tante volte purtroppo la sua memoria a
livello meno finito cioè pensa te lo
guarda ti dico che io lo stesso l'ho
provato un sacco di volte lo stesso
riesca a rifarla è impossibile schivare
sti cosi la copre abbastanza fattibile è
inutile che glieli piano se fossi in
mezzo alle trappole e no perché poi
dovresti saltare due blocchi non ce la
fai perché deve arrivare alla fine mio
zio quanto tempo fa è uscito allora
uscita da un mesetto qui devi venire
devi passare in mezzo a questi due a
quei salti jeda e specie untuoso però 50
ma credibile aree ancora non è finita
ce l'ho fatta lo stesso ok per la
rischio incredibile a kit di blackrock è
finito abbiamo finito questo video
tingerò che i primi livelli sono tutti
fattibilissimi davis ero io quando sei
volte impossibile ma aspetta le fatto il
primo tra i no no quasi perché dovevo
saltare prima
rientra sul collo ok dopo il che è un
parco era abbastanza ii iii e iv e sarà
molto allora quello non te lo spiego
petricci danni un pochino grazie gentile
già siamo partiti male prova allora lo
stato all'ultimo secondo
esatto la cisl er seppure al field mai
furbizia fortuna e mai fortuna purtroppo
mente orribile da provare
mio dio all'arancia con la vostra un
attimo tieni premuto sei un l'impulso ok
quindi ce l'hai già che così vedi la
traiettoria si punti a metter terra
sotto i piedi fai un passo salti e voli
verso avanti
a quel punto di vista tanto a capire da
dove partire è quanto saltare eccetera
eccetera prima o poi ci finisci dentro
che ho capito da che punto però ti
conviene
da qui
mio dio un casino ferma dove sei tu
quello uno che ancora li vedevo le nuove
reti poi tanto quando lo fa fatto
cestari avarissimo credibile allora ti
voglio dare una brutta notizia
hydra impulso e sono tre salti da fare
con l'impulso ok
praticamente il suo obiettivo andare
sopra quel pilastro questo proprio in
fondo e poi dentro quella porta
cambiamo gioco non ma no dai io cerco
ridolfi romano perché questo sarà un
patatrac perché se non ne vedo
dell'impulso allora mi ha impiegato o
riusciva più ad ora è confidente confida
male ci provo
signori questa è andrà messo
praticamente della punta massima
fai così e salti ok è difficile questa
farlo senza me morire impossibile però
quantomeno pochi tentativi ok 1 fatto
yes
adesso punta massima non ci arrivo per
melo rape cosa stai sbagliando di fare
un passetto in più dopo l'impulso quindi
superando leggermente di più e poi
saltare però ci sei a ok
gl purtroppo vai vai vai vai vai
ok perfetto trovata
ok ad aspettarmi lì perché lui è un
dramma si sia che faccia ci si mette
così all indietro si inizia a camminare
bisogna proprio stare nel limbo si
raggiunge il punto massimo poi si punta
un po più verso la sinistra vedi che so
praticamente fluttuando ok a questo
punto deve osservare la porta rigirarti
capire la direzione parare l'impulso e
cercare dentro c'è dentro
capisco ok ho capito che ricorda sempre
tutto questo livello 5 su 16 o grava
bene poi ciclo benissimo ti propagando
poi metallizzato il turismo elezioni con
un esame ma devo fluttuare francese va
benissimo così ad esso mira abbastanza
vicino al loro corpo no no no no devi
mirare per terra dovesse esatto per
quello disegnato emiri un pochino dopo
di te in modo tale che ti colpisca che
ti sbalzi verso la porta è però la porta
dove centrale aspetta quindi air luz è
un salto al contrario praticamente mio
dio ragazzi orribile orribile ma poi il
tipo che l'ha creata la testata anche
misure queste toni riesce a farla quindi
aspettiamo questa mappa i 16 livelli
sono stati finiti in sei minuti a bada
un ora e ci saremo un'altra ora debutto
qui ragazzi
veramente ma io non ho mai giocato a una
roba così in tutta la mia vita cioè non
so cosa dire e questa per i semplici ma
come e dopo cosa c'è in giro è arrivata
anche per la paura perché stasera
l'imposta niente dai non usciremo mai
d'accordo allora ok calmiamoci prima
secondo me era giusto e lo sbagliato
traiettoria
anche secondo me era solo la traiettoria
ma io mi sposta anche stesso tutto
l'ingresso è libero
basta basta evince bravo vai sempre meno
dimenticato mio bagno la mia formale a
razzo adesso è concentrata mente e
simula cosa sarebbe successo se fossi
morto lì pensa in live no ed è successo
mandiamo diamo ai fornitori corridori
fortino ragazza mi aspetta aspetta tanto
adesso di un oggetto inquini chi si
riferisse cominciò paura a parlà sera
scatta poi ricorri doyle riferire mamma
mia ragazzi devi saltare si conserva mi
libero non ti puoi fermare quindi di
riuscire a fare tutto è un calo di no so
su quali su quali tutti ad evitare su
tutti quanti è tutto un percorso di fila
saltando ok ho capito perché se ti fermi
per di il turbo e quindi poi non
riusciamo perdi totalmente però non è
abbastanza slancio è questo livello
quando noi eravamo fatto aveva un bug
che contando che aveva il bug abbiamo
messo un'ora e mezzo orribile ci sono i
tutti lontanissimi
a nova per haga e l'inferno quando siamo
al 6 su 16 arrivare ma no ma dai ma no
no il dio del pd
non riesco a fare il secondo come l'età
dt fattibile molto poco avevo molto
molto difficile
ok bravo alessandro nuovo piano mamma
mia è quello di riprendere tutta la
rincorsa esaltare vai è facile poiché
adesso ti puoi fermare lì
ok allora adesso tutto semplice tranne
quello che sta tutto attaccato al muro
dalla parte opposta di dove siete voi
beretti dove c'è più un fondo verde
rifare per forza la strisciata sul muro
altrimenti è impossibile fare il salto
dopo nell'ultimo tv aiuti vidi puoi
fermare quindi voi che faccio tutto di
fila però di sicuro devi fare quella
strisciata no l'ho fatta non l'ho fatto
ho capito un quesito che io non ho
capito molto
sì no no la strisciata lo capite o no
porca vacca fermarmi lì lì di vista
recare perché vero preso ormai nero
preso allora praticamente è così
12 ok ma poi si che tutto grover
avessimo potuto finire ma era me
interessava la bella non ci credo non ci
credo il vivere
ok piano piano ma ci vorrebbe un check
point tutta la vita è già quella che lo
sai fare
lo sai fare posso fare sono forte
proprio lui si ferma per ma fermo come
si cosa sia la regola si sono trappole
ma basta queste trappole quanto sei
fifone da una di esse è senti c'è
nessuna vita io non ci voglio veramente
credere uefa timbro è questo ma i
ragazzi orribile è stato orribile
una roba veramente ma guardate che
finisce l'orribile inizia subito
si no ma poi continua c'è questo qua si
è fatto gli incubi per fare stare
sì non sai quante volte l'abbiamo
insultato e poi io ho l'auto forza nel
gioco quindi non posso decidere di non
correre a wow perché ci auto posto
school e perché è comodissima sempre
pensa non dover premere shift tutta la
vita però ogni tanto capita che più
scomodo
la potente da visitare pronto ce l'ho
fatta occhio dovuto ritirare l'ho fatta
no c'erano 200 noi almeno una volta ti
devo far crollare
no dai non poté no dai non ho veramente
ho fatto crollare il livello cui avuto
meno difficoltà veramente niente grande
è stato arrivi anche sapere manco se lo
ricordava è no io non me lo ricordavo io
poi a pratiche quelli non l'ho fatto
quindi non l'ho finito quindi non so se
volete colaci poste dopo mi sono
bloccata prima di te non sono arrivata
al 10 con ricarica ricaricare gara
lettere ma team bulls e per me possiamo
concludere qua ragazzi va benissimo
e capita se se se c'è ma guarda voglio
voglio anche sperare di non toccare più
questo niente ragazzi io ringrazio sul
player swan console per avermi dato una
mano in questa mappa impossibile faremo
il sequel 2150 non per come al solito se
il video vi è piaciuto lasciato momento
mi piace iscrivetevi al canale di to
play a sky trovato in descrizione e io
vi dico che ci vediamo
beh ragazzi
[Musica]